on this island few places feel safe
goramara was hit by a cyclone six months
ago
it left many with nothing
temporary shelters are now permanent
homes
so is this
this is where you're living at the
moment
sanawara's family lost everything
this shack now houses five people
second of all
here there is already no line between
land and water few believe this island
will be habitable by 2070 the year india
the world's third largest polluter says
it'll finally be net zero
even now salt water from the rising sea
is poisoning fresh water reserves
we've got this meter here we're going to
take a measurement of the salt content
in this
pond and it feeds into all the paddies
around here and
theoretically it's the end of the
monsoon season so this should be the
freshest this water is ever going to be
let's take a look but yeah even then
it's measuring
0.2
so that means not only is this water
still too salty um for people to grow
rice in but it's also unsafe to drink
in these salty ponds
there are now desperate attempts to try
and save what's left to make the island
more resistant to intensifying cyclones
but many families have already left to a
nearby bigger island
arrived from guramara eight years ago
with nothing
but now this home like every other
across the indian sunderbans is at risk
of
foreign
there are already calls for a planned
retreat
one million people could be displaced
forced from their homes
from these islands that are slowly but
surely disappearing
catherine rivertotsi sky news in the
indian sunderbans